[Music]
when i was a little tyke my grandfather
my father's father grandpa long
he um he had a chair i remember he had
this uh remember his chair that kind of
like it was a mechanic i thought it was
so cool it pushed him up it was a great
tv watching chair an armchair and it
went like
and like kind of pushed him up it was
like a lazy boy before lazy boys existed
yes it was a lazier boy because he was
so lazy that it was like a lazy man
lazyman
and uh he used to love westerns i'd sit
there and watch with him but they all
seem the same to me like
you know like john wayne seemed to be in
every one of them and uh
and he would always say to me did you
see this one and i always felt like i
wish i had i wish i cause i wanted to
connect you know and because he wanted
to connect yeah exactly
and uh so then
my young mind was blown when i saw a
movie called young guns it was the first
time it was a western it was a western
with like cool current hip actors that i
knew that were cool to me like kiefer
sutherland and christian slater emilio
estevez the coolest
and so i remember saying to him uh hey
he said did you see this one when we
were watching some old john wayne movie
and i said no but um have you seen
young guns and he kind of
looked at me blankly and i said with and
i just rattled off the list of you know
charlie sheen and lou diamond phillips
and
uh no and you know just different
generations and we just we we missed the
connect of potential connections passing
in the night yeah but you know what i
bet in retrospect he appreciated your
attempt at connecting just as you in
retrospect appreciate his attempt
exactly it's all in the uh intention his
intent amen yes and here we go and
hopefully your intention is to listen to
life is short because you're about to
don't go anywhere life could be a dream
life could be a dream
you're listening to life is short i'm
your host justin long life could be a
dream sweetheart
and with me as always is say that again
i'm your host justin long i got that
part and with me as always i'm still
with me as always
too much coffee maybe uh oh this is
gonna be interesting
with me as always
is you just mouthed the words like
waiting for god man
you're like catherine
uh yeah my my brother mostly my co-host
your addiction coach yeah
yeah
uh is that what it's called addiction
coach yeah i don't know i guess so um
two sits in solemn silence an adult dark
duck in a pestilence well i can't do a
pestilential prison with a lifelong lock
god we made uh in the movie that we have
coming out in august or september later
the manner we made judy greer do we made
it's in the script she's an actress
um she got paid to do it
she was very good at it too um she had
to do what was the one to sit that
yeah
uh that was a tricky one but she gosh he
nailed it
uh that's it that was a tricky window
what's the whole thing we might as well
do it anyway hi everybody
oh no uh why are we so weird so you yeah
so my name's christian you never
introduced me
should we do this again no
okay
um you don't like westerners new
listeners oh man who are tuning in for
our guest today are going to be
pleasantly surprised by this banter the
episode
that the show unraveled
i just went off the rails uh why did you
were you into westerns
i was into young guns exactly that
that's the movie you don't both have to
be into young guns you know both have to
not have like westerns until you saw
young guns then it changed the way you
saw the genre oh it was the coolest
though young one's one and
i might have liked young guns too even
more i think you don't both have to like
young ones a lot but like young's two
more i think i did too because um you
know why it's the addition of the two
cool new cast members yes and the
edition of
oh wow our guest today soundtrack the
soundtrack was so cool i mean the whole
thing was cool but it's like you know i
wonder if in the first one they were
like god everything about this is cool
um
but we we could even
and maybe it made somebody cool like our
guests today
say they wanted to participate like feel
cool you know feel like okay about
participating in the second one if there
was a drinking game where every time we
said cool on this episode oh my god
people wouldn't make it very long no
you'll you'll be wasted before the end
of the intro but that was a pretty
uncool way of saying that wasted you'll
be wasted by the end of the intro
would the word uncool count if you were
doing the cool drinking game no well why
because cool's in the word it doesn't
matter it's also we're not going to say
uncool
nearly as
many times we might if we're talking
about ourselves in comparison to our
cool that's true so our guest today is
someone who's always been cool in our
lives yeah jon bon jovi ah man and um
after this talk that i had i was the
first time i met him he he's even cooler
continues to be cool uh we were talking
about this in the context of uh jon bon
jovi who else in our lives do we talk
about this on the show who else in our
lives has been cool consistently
throughout our lives we talked about
this privately the other day um so we
didn't talk about on the show okay
sometimes i don't know
well we were born justin was born in the
late 70s i was born in the early 80s so
to try to think of someone who
has in our entire memory let's say we
start having memories back to when
you're what four or five years old right
in my memory in my life
i've always known who bon jovi is always
yeah and he's always been cool yeah i'm
almost 40 years old now and he's still
cool so it's hard to think of people
who
i've always known to be cool and who are
still cool well it's very hard to think
of a list i know we were gentle
washington denzel washington michael
jordan yes always been cool um who else
we had a couple others that were like oh
yeah
because springsteen yep yeah billy joel
yep
um
but didn't you argue that he went
through a phase the river of dreams
phase was not
not as cool but he's but he remains cool
oh you were [ __ ] all over river
dreams like
okay
he's got the john bon jovi soul
foundation which does
so much great work they opened they just
opened a food
bank during um during covid during
millions of dollars they've they've
raised
so much money and he himself has
actually
done work i mean he deserves food at
food kitchens yeah he is cool he is like
he really uh walks the walk yeah i mean
if you met somebody like that who who
did that who just did that that was what
they did it'd be like oh [ __ ] what a
great what a good person what a cool
person but in addition to that he's
jon bon jovi he sings those songs
and the latest songs oh yeah great this
great album out 2020 2012 very easy to
remember yeah it's called 2020.
and um it's awesome we've been listening
to it the last few days and
it is um it's like there's elements of
classic bon jovi in there but there's
but it feels very current because the
songs are mostly all about
what's happening in the world now
everyone will be able to relate to
lyrically to them let's get into it
let's talk to him about the album his
philanthropic endeavors and a lot of
other things that make him cool uh just
how easy he was to talk to i think was
the coolest thing for me but uh you're
about you're about to hear it i was
stuck between words you're about to hear
it so here it is um
my talk with the
incredibly effortlessly cool um
decades long cool jon bon jovi life
could be a dream sweetheart
hello hello again you're booming over
we'll meet again
[Music]
john pleasure what a pleasure look at
that room what are those photos there oh
um
those were a wedding gift from my first
manager
oh wow
they were uh
not andy warhol's andy was sick by then
but uh
peter max did those uh but they're
nostalgic because it's my wife and i how
cool and you guys have been what a great
story what a rare story you've been
together forever yeah yeah cool 40 years
ago
god
good lord i mean it's funny i
uh john
of all the the things you've
accomplished um
that's something i
i probably admire the most about about
you that's like the most
thing of the many things
are you married i'm not no and um
you know to be totally candid i think
one of my big difficulties is just the
uh at a certain age there were just so
many options
i don't know how to say that without
sounding like an [ __ ]
but you know for like a nerdy kid from
connecticut it was like
i just wanted to
try too much
you're in the candy box and you're like
oh
got it
yeah so again i mean i'm much better now
i've matured i think um
i don't want to
you know interview you 42.
yeah yeah i should be lying down for
this
[Laughter]
and we grew up similarly too i think uh
two brothers catholic family yeah i have
two younger brothers yeah oh they're
both younger and what did they were you
guys close growing up john yeah and as
much as we could be because there was
such an age difference um my brother
tony's just shy of five years younger
and then my younger brother matt
has got to be 13 years younger so to him
i think i was an adult you know and even
five years at that time you know when
you're kids that's a
that's a gap you don't have the same
friends or even the same ex you know
likes and we got we all got closer as we
got older
and my younger brother matt is the one
that spends the most time with me
professionally he'd always be like my
body guy but um
i think by the time he was six or seven
years old i had a record deal
so
well it was certainly eight eight or
nine so by then i you know so he sort of
grew up you know in second grade and i
had a record deal so everything he's
ever known has been
i was that to him so
was he must have gotten a lot of mileage
out of that as like a
junior high high schooler like my
brother's
yeah it worked as you well know then it
worked positively and negatively you
know to have siblings that uh
who lived in your shadow so that that
did it had its benefits and
things that were seriously detrimental
but overall you know it's it's all good
well you also seem like um i i've seen
you on a bunch of talk shows and i
recently saw you on a uh like that pizza
tasting show yes uh where you you ran
into nicholas bronze yes on the street
the actor yes yes love that show
i love it it strikes me how down to
earth you seem considering
the things you've done and and
the arenas you've played and the amount
of adulation you've has that's been
showered on you i always
and even now i you seem so unassuming
and
hey are you just there's it's uh that is
really admirable too and i wonder um it
was probably easier for your brothers
because you don't seem like a it ever
went to your head or or did it and if so
how did you adjust i i don't think
anyone in the band let it go to their
head and a lot of it had to do with our
being from here even at the height of
our
initial you know explosion to fame which
was our third album and slippery and wet
um
i remember many a conversation during
that period when we would say to each
other
we're the same right
they're all changing and that was the
internal conversation
um suddenly you know you're 25 and the
head of a major corporation as opposed
to being a seer in a rock band and your
parents are asking you for advice and
you're thinking i don't know anything
more than i knew last year
why are you asking me now
what did it then just seem that like
that john was it just twilight zoney and
and
weird
did it ever did you ever find yourself
attempting to give your parents advice
or
caring yourself like you knew more than
you
did sure
who wouldn't
yeah who wouldn't
but i think that we
were all aware
that it wasn't us it was it and
slippery when wet led into new jersey
which was another massively big record
for us
and then we got physically burned out
too much touring
too many tv shows and and so we were
just burned and by the end of it we
didn't know why we were gonna not be
working
for a long period of time but we knew
that that was necessary and so you know
that's when i went off and did young
guns and that whole world started for me
but the guys we all had to be
independent of the it
because god blessed them in retrospect
but the managers agents lawyers they
were trying to do their job but what
their job was doing was killing the
individuals and it's an age-old story
any
you know justin timberlake just you know
had that a couple years ago generations
of kids it's always going to be the same
thing
you know the burnout
they're just trying to suck as much out
of you they're trying to uh squeeze i'm
old enough to say that it's not sucking
anything out of anything it's it's that
they're all just trying to do their job
you know i think that that if i were
ever to be in the position that i were
managing a kid or being the agent or be
the father of a kid
i would tell them to have enough faith
in their talent that they could take a
whole year go to sleep
i'll wake you up in a year you know just
you need two years to get the next
record or movie together
that's fine don't worry about it you
know but falling victim to the to the
treadmill compounded by the fact that
celebrity feeds you a bunch of nonsense
that you really shouldn't have believed
and you know all those things i could
write that book now
but in and of the moment who who knew
you know
did you and you must have seen that
happen to a lot of your colleagues i
mean i'm sure most of them most of them
yeah most of them you know whether how
many how many gold stars did you get for
going to rehabs or you're no longer
viable as a act or an actor or
you know or how many marriages and
divorces or are you got any money left
or sure i've seen chapters on end about
that you know i've seen that for i've
been around far too long to not have
seen a lot of that
yeah and and
every time you see it does it solidify
the choices that you made does it make
you feel better about
i mean being with the same person being
grounded
returning to new jersey those did it
kind of reinforce those you know i i
can't speak for anyone else so that that
would be a terrible assumption to make
based on that question and and the trite
answer which would be of course i'm a
genius yeah but that wasn't yeah that
wasn't it that wouldn't be fair to
anyone else but but
for me
uh you know i i can look
from afar and say these are choices that
i made whether or not they they were
right throughout the 40 years or not
um but they were the choices i made
um you mentioned uh john young guns that
being kind of a turning point uh in your
career and do you you knew those i see
that i was like a huge
young that's i was just a nut like a
young guns i thought that was the
coolest i mean it was it was the coolest
um
yeah did you know those guys is that how
you got into that
uh the world in the movie no i was a fan
like anyone else and and truthfully i
didn't know very many actors and i
certainly didn't know any you know movie
stars
um but richie was dating ali sheedy
and from the brat pack
and uh and of course she was very close
to emilio
and after
young guns and before young guns too
um emilio said that they would like to
use wanted dead or alive in their film
and i said i could write you something
specific for the movie and uh and so i
went out to the set and at that time in
my life i was looking for something else
i didn't know what that something was
but something and i went out to my first
movie set
and
my takeaway honestly was this i said you
all you guys
you learn
other hobbies while you're making a film
and typically in this case they learned
how to shoot a gun they learned how to
ride a horse they you know they they
learned things that up until that point
in my career all i did was make a record
tour make a record tour we had nothing
left to talk about because we didn't
have hobbies it's all we knew
you know so strangely enough
that was appealing to me when i went out
to that movie set and then they said hey
you know so be cute why don't you
be an extra in this jail scene okay
and then when i came home i said i need
to start to look into this and then i
started to study and i and i took years
of lessons after that and it helped me
grow as an artist and as a writer and it
had a study activity yeah yeah i studied
acting i guess for
i don't know four or five years before i
got my first roll and then they were
small no [ __ ] which again it helped me
and i loved
immensely the craft of acting i loved it
immensely but it seemed to me that any
time i'd get even a little spark and get
the opportunity at a bigger role i would
disappear for a long period of time
because we'd be making a record
and and i finally confronted
my agents and everybody and said
what what's the problem i thought i was
doing so well and they said you have to
take this
seriously you have to
choose and at the time if you think
about it it's one of the other whether
it was will smith
or
ice tea or sting or madonna or you know
yeah
bill collins
all of those guys before i'm talking
like you know 90.
um yeah you had to choose either or
you weren't doing both
kid or play you you know you had to
choose and and i said well we're too
successful musically and until i you
know i can't make the same money and i'm
really loving making records so i can't
and so therefore the quality
of the role i was being offered was
getting to be embarrassing already so
you know i hung it up that's
but what great choices i mean it's like
you're choosing between great
it's great and a great it brought such
humility back to the music business you
were studying the classics you were
reading you know the classic playwrights
or or
or commercial things that appealed to
you and coming from the folding chair in
the audition room
which is humility at its best yeah to
going back tell me being on the big
stage
it was great for me because i i could
take that humility back to music oh
that's interesting and that helps answer
this i mean i i'm it's going to keep
coming up because it really does
fascinate me how you
man i met a lot of people and
not many in your rarified position but
but the few that i've met strike me as
having some
again i'm generalizing but but you just
seem so
normal and
uh unaffected by all of this um
uh are you still are you so you said
you're close now with your siblings um
and one of them
kind of worked with you uh both of them
both of them do well we're touring yeah
yeah oh that's cool um so all that stuff
is it's all been ironed out and now you
guys are just close and it's uh yeah
because we all grew up and one of them
directs the video program of the show so
he's not necessarily going to be with me
and the other one is my my body guy if
you will uh he's my right hand you know
matt's like six foot four and huge so it
looks like more oh my god so
um because so that's just how it worked
out you know but yeah did six foot four
i know i'm 510 what what happened to me
yeah
yeah so he did get some of the um
he did get some cool things uh did they
play music you started as a teenager
playing guitar and piano um
why
those instruments how did you choose
those
well the guitar seemed like the cool
thing and every kid wanted to go be a
rock and roll star um
so you you know you'd pick up a guitar
and if it didn't work out it didn't set
your family back even if they had had
room for a piano in the house so you
know i think that's what i gravitated
towards and then i ultimately just ended
up the singer simply because no one else
wanted to do it
and um
one thing did you sing it's
did you sing in school and church did
you did you always have an aptitude i i
let's just say i always liked it i don't
know that it always liked me or the
teachers believed that i had any future
in it i don't think that i was ever uh
you know in the in their top three for
anything
but uh really never never never isn't
that funny
no and i know
you won't be able to uh intelligently
mean this i know because you're not a
look at me haha look at me guy but
i'm now imagining your teachers who
who were like well no not john i know
absolutely
absolutely yeah no that's that's not
true i was just having a conversation
with my mother
the other day and she she recalls the
story much differently than i do but she
then admitted to the truth she said
remember the first time you came off
this stage at a talent contest with your
first band and i said yeah i remember
you told me you wanted to crawl under
the seats and then it was horrible and
she at first was like no i didn't say
that and then about 20 minutes later she
goes yeah i think i did
oh my god i was like that's okay it gave
me the motivation it's what you know
again all of that gave me motivation
i'm also i may be cherry-picking this
information but like data mining for for
to answer the question of how you did p
how you do have so much humility but um
that'll do it i'll do it
how old were you when that happened
i was really young i couldn't have been
15-ish
you know why but
and but did you have you must have um
had a real drive you must have had
confidence to get up and do yeah never
lacked for confidence ever uh never
never ever yeah and the cheap popular no
no being in a rock band in high school
in the late 70s was not something that
anyone really did there was a couple of
us uh
but no no no i wasn't the athlete or the
the the tough kid you know or the
greaser i was i was
i looked at it as sort of a life
sentence you know get me through school
just free me let me go
you know and and because the drinking
age in new jersey was 18.
this is really key to my success because
the drinking age was 18 you could be 16
and then 17 when you just got good
enough to play in a bar
that was interesting that was integral
because you could go there and watch you
could go there and participate you could
go there and actually you know have a
direction and and an idea of who you
wanted to be
and so by the time i graduated high
school there was no plan b
there was no plan wow but and what was
that
and what was it john it was just the was
it i mean uh if you can reduce it to
something like a feeling was it just a
feeling of being on stage was it the the
the atmosphere the girls the the
everything in your youth i mean that's
all the naive sure sure it was girls on
the stage
i think that there was this just kind of
innate kind of rebellion
that
if school was setting me up for the
cubicle
and that's what life was and it wasn't
an adventure
then what's the point you know and we
had a very nice very easy middle class
new jersey upbringing it certainly
wasn't you know the wrong side of the
tracks but but all of our families had
to work two jobs you know like my mother
and father worked six days a week to
make sure that we had a roof and food
and you know and all the
they could buy me a guitar but so that
that kind of work ethic was instilled in
you but the idea of me doing that and i
remember it
in the late 70s you get a phone call
from the recruiting office of the
service and they say
we've got an idea come and see the world
join the navy and my three best friends
said yes
and there was four of us and my three
best friends said yes and i was like
not unless the uniforms come in
different colors and i can grow my you
know as the wise guy i was like there's
no chance i'm playing tuesday and
thursday and and so they truly the only
way out was to join the service and
i was going to be an event so and it was
um
so this the sense that you're you you'd
be confined um yeah i remember having
that fear uh and i don't know how i was
exposed to it because my dad was a
teacher and my mom
was an actress a struggling actress but
a good actress but i had this fear of
like um being a drone you know fear of
uh you mentioned you said cubicle uh
being in a cubicle that that always
being confined like that always really
freaked me out um
and
that must have been i would imagine just
wanting
the freedom the freedom of the beautiful
thing about that 18 year old comment i
made before was that i didn't have to
get
that far down the road where i had to
worry about someone else or a paycheck
when you're 16 and 17 i'm still in high
school i was able to come home at night
you know but uh when you come home at
night and say i just i did something
better than i did yesterday or
you know because we lived so close to
asbury park and it encouraged live music
and south side johnny and bruce
springsteen were already established big
by our standards by our standards big
recording artists and there were so many
guys in each of those two bands chances
are you literally would walk into them
on the boardwalk or in a nightclub
no [ __ ] yeah the first time bruce jumped
on stage with me i was 17 years old
get out of here no you know those were
our beatles
yeah oh my god
and john when that happened are you you
must are you
awestruck are you uh
had you never met him socially no i mean
this is the guy that wrote the songs
about the places where you were walking
down the street south side johnny
produced some of the first demos i was
some the singer in someone else's band
but south side johnny produced the demos
you know bruce jumped up on stage with
me there was there was that kind i was
you know the kid i was known as you know
oh the kid the kid's pretty good the
kid's all right
you know and so those memories made for
milestones in my life at that time
[Music]
in the early 2000s millions of
households across the world tuned in to
watch contestants battle for the last
rose or to be the final survivor on the
island reality tv was beginning to
dominate the airwaves and every show
needed to be bigger flashier more
scandalous than the last but in the case
of one infamous dating show the real
drama was happening off-screen and it
would shape the future of reality tv the
reality tv series there's something
about miriam seemed like a pretty
standard dating competition six young
men vibed for the affection of miriam
rivera a beautiful model from mexico but
when miriam revealed that she was a
trans woman during the show's finale the
on-screen drama sparked an international
uproar about gender sexuality and
whether reality television had finally
gone too far follow harsh reality the
story of miriam rivera on apple podcast
amazon music or you can listen early and
add free by joining wondering plus in
apple podcasts or the wondery app
[Music]
hello hello again
i mean i don't know how to ask this but
a generic thing to say but how how can
you walk me through
the excitement and the what are you
feeling when this is all happening to me
is this they were the beatles but in
in in teenage terms
neither of them could play an arena or
or have hit or have hit songs they were
making records
but they weren't big yet you know if
that makes any sense so yeah you know
aerosmith was big leonard skinner it was
the late 70s it was it was it was all
that it was queen it was alice cooper it
was led zeppelin
that was big but guys billy joel billy
billy
yeah billy was of course making records
too but i wouldn't say that billy was
bigger than bruce i think they were
successful but not
they weren't you know in in in the
center fold of circus magazine the way
that led zeppelin would have been if
that makes sense so you know it made the
impossible possible that's the bot
that's the bottom line i see yeah and so
you it now is uh it's not just like this
pipe dream at this point you're
performing with these people who are
bona fide
not regularly but the idea was that you
could touch them they were there yeah
they were there they made the impossible
possible
you know and and that that was important
and then how quickly did it take off in
the sense that you didn't have to do
another job or you're you're now able to
support yourself because i could live at
home
um
there was no overhead to to to worry
about and when you were writing your own
songs and even at the time when i was in
someone's band who was the songwriter um
[Music]
there was no money in that there was no
money in that there was a hundred
dollars to split between the band if you
were lucky and so that that there wasn't
a way to make a living but even at 18
years old i was smart enough to have
quit my own cover band and say to my
school chums
sorry boys but the only way to have a
life in this is to go and make you know
your own music
and so i i did that how did you know
that you say you're smart enough but
where did that thing there were so many
imitations
of
bruce and john
and those guys down there that you would
you knew even at 18 years old that's the
real one and that's the one who wishes
he was that and that's never going to
happen for him
even at 18 i knew that
i was like the only way to do this is to
go and figure out who you want to be
and and and create that
so i quit and so
so what's that process like john how do
you go from recognizing that to then uh
cultivating your own
sound your own voice right and in and of
that moment i was in a 10-piece band
with horns and as i was talking to a guy
that really was a carbon copy of
springsteen and i'm thinking that's
kooky you're 10 years older than me
what's what's your excuse you know i'm
i'm trying to
to be southside johnny over here and i
go i feel like i'm in the muppets it's
time to leave
so he's like i'm goosey yeah right
pretty much you know so yeah i i i quit
my own band
and i became the singer
of someone else's band
singing
pop rock early 80s new wave sounding
stuff but
learning
the craft
learning what four chords make for
a song and you know the first one the
first five the first 10 songs that band
was short-lived but from there i had a
springboard and two it was only two
years later that i wrote runaway
so you know by then
it it it never looked
back so runaway is then done through how
do you
uh you you have to you're now kind of
known uh somewhat in the business
not really but i i had i had played a
bunch of times on the short no not not
to the
not to the tune of of drawing more than
a hundred people to come and see you
but i had gotten the most amazing demo
of runaway and a whole lot of other
songs without the band without the band
at all
and
by this time i was so frustrated because
i had sent it around to managers labels
tried to you know connections to when i
was playing in the club a lot
and
i had a a thought i'm gonna go
to a radio station this radio station
happened to be just outside of new york
saying they were broadcasting in new
york they were so new they didn't have a
receptionist
that too was was god because they didn't
have a receptionist i could go in and
bang on the window of the dj's booth
and i got his attention now after his
shift he came out he spoke to me
small talk he said we're going to do a
homegrown record of local talent he says
and by the way that song sounds like
it's a hit
and before you knew it i was on the
radio in new york without a band manager
lawyers anything holy [ __ ] what was that
that was runaway no no way and it was a
brand new radio station called wapp
and a dj by the name of chip hobart and
i was on the double day radio chain and
all those same
a r guys and managers were all looking
around their desk for that cassette that
i had sent all through new york and l.a
wow wow isn't that funny in app the app
gave you your start before enough funny
technology
yeah yeah and
i i wonder if
and was the guy pit was the guy like kid
get out of here i
no he
got it because they were new and he
wanted to endear himself to the
community and no one else was really
there there was a person or two around
the studio i mean it literally looked
like a construction scene outside of the
the the dj's booth and they were
broadcasting commercial free all summer
but i had a crazy thought and that's
just the way i've always been is i think
differently so i thought who's the
loneliest man in the music business a dj
who likes music more than a dj
you know so he sits there with his
record in his headphones and tries to
preach to the masses with no idea if
anyone's listening
you know that's that's passion
you know wow i i was i was funny i
wonder who that guy was
he must know oh god yeah i've seen him
you know a hundred times since
when we got in the in the rock roll hall
of fame
i was relating that story and then uh
after the speech i was in the press room
and i heard a voice and he stood up and
it was the guy it was
and i dragged him up on stage and he had
one of the old satin jackets on from the
early 80s and the band all took pictures
with them because it was a moment in in
our history
that's awesome that is awesome um
this this might be a dumb question uh
don't you love questions
[Laughter]
this is probably really dumb
but uh why did you name your latest
album is your 15th studio album
2020. well in march of 19 we went to
nashville to make what i thought was the
record
and in retrospect really was just the
first batch of songs
typically i'll write a couple of topical
songs on a record but never the entire
thing
as we recorded the record and what was
now
roughly a year ago now march of 20.
i think the record's done i started to
actually do some early promotion
uh and i was in the uk
uh
re-recording a song called unbroken
which is about vets with ptsd
with prince harry
with harry at abbey road
for the british military his last week
of
acting as prince and his duties
his first event was with me and so we
record well he hasn't been in the news
so we should wait
um was he what was he doing on the
record was he doing something amusing he
is the
face of the british military obviously
having been a pilot and a soldier for
nearly a decade and
he's uh the patron saint of their
uh invictus games which is sort of like
their uh
para olympics and so they have a choir
and so i had uh sent him the song and i
says our military are going to use this
i wrote it for a documentary
would you want to do this and he says i
get it and so we went to abbey road just
a year ago
and recorded the song so we come back
here it's the first week of what becomes
covid
things started to get crazy and the
shutdown's happening i pull the plug on
the record i then decide to cancel
outright the tour because i'm concerned
that people need their money for credit
cards and rent and things like that and
now i'm holding this record
but the um
the the idea of it being topical was
making more and more sense to me so i
considered that i could open up the can
of worms again dig deeper into a bunch
of these songs
and i started to tweak them and then
when covid went into lockdown i wrote do
what you can
about the covet crisis and then after
the george floyd death i couldn't help
but write
american reckoning so now this this
record that i initially thought 2020 was
clear vision and how cute will it be for
a
campaign poster
turned into a very topical
um serious record but one that i'm very
proud of because i think it marked a
moment in time
sure and
it's
i'm so grateful you were able to go back
in i bet you are to go back in there and
and had it come out and you missed an
opportunity to to really
speak about what was all the changes
that were taking place yeah you know
it's you know what's the [ __ ] about
this one justin is that he put it out in
this vacuum
known as 20 20 and and it's sort of
heartbreaking because you know two years
work went into it
and yeah it's out and i can't hear it
and you can't even go to a
a tv show and play or
or anything i know you got to do these
shitty podcasts and talk about it
um i know john it must be so weird for
you i mean somebody who is
i'm sure has derived so much joy from
playing and you've played the best
venues and and that's the thing right
you you
you to wear an album that's just like
how it goes it must be so weird
because i don't know the reception to
the record i know the fan base really
like it but when you can't go out and
work it
it's not like i sit in the house
listening to the radio you know it's
like
it's very hard right to to
wrap my head around that the record's
out you know
right and for songs like how else do you
tell
whether you're actually playing them for
people how else do you feel
uh
the responsibilities you don't unlike
anyone yeah you know every time you
write a record
you think it's the best thing you've
ever done okay so you know there you are
in and of that moment and if it's not
it's not but you think it is that's why
you want to release it
so with this record what is different is
i didn't have the experience of
performing those songs live
so i don't know if they work or not
there have been songs on previous
records that i swore on my life that
song's this match
at i wonder you know and it doesn't work
the song doesn't work live and you go i
don't know what's missing
i did everything i could that one didn't
work
you know huh so this one this is the
this one's the twilight zone
uh are there john and conversely are
there ones that are hits or like people
just eat them up and you're like ah i
didn't see that coming well my greatest
story is that living on a prayer you
know i didn't know i honestly didn't
know
uh it was really well for a number of
reasons but first and foremost it was so
unique and so different than anything on
the radio at the time
that i i was i was like well i know we
created something but maybe we should
just give it to that soundtrack and and
you know richie was like you're crazy uh
this is special and of course it came to
life when we got with the band
and did it in pre-production and then
ultimately recorded it but in and of the
moment that was a classic case of i was
completely wrong
wow and
then you record it and right away do you
when you get this when you feel the
energy of it no because it wasn't the
first single you know we were we were
again it was so different
again
in 1986
um tears for fears and
uh power station were on the radio i
mean it didn't sound like things on the
radio um
rock
music in that way wasn't in the
brightest light
in and of that moment from 86 with
slippery
until probably close to 90
rock and roll had a
a a resurgence a big you know a big wave
yeah thanks in part to you can't say it
because you're a humble
person but thanks in large part to you
uh
it must have felt it so what were those
were those the years that we was just
like
non-stop we're
i mean on this
level that four other people can relate
to were those the
years yeah
let me tell you something my brother the
hedonistic 80s were everything that they
said they were
you know and and being in a rock band
and being jon bon jovi in a rock band
was pretty [ __ ] good
it's funny i i'm sure people
always dance around that with you i i
would imagine they
because everyone wants to know you know
just like you did when you were a kid
everybody wants to know what that feels
like and there's no way to ask that and
i'm sure there's no way to really answer
it without well you got to get into that
yeah some stuff you know again i'm so
far removed from the it that i was never
not right not me but the truth is you
could tell a little bit more of the
truth without giving it all away and the
truth is we had a lot of fun
yeah
when when it was happening when it was
like the most fun do you remember
thinking do you ever have that moment
where you're like i this is it's
it's this is the best it's never going
to like this it can't get any better
than this and like we're going to look
back
so we should soak it up we should enjoy
it
i think that every step if you're asking
even from the the professional
journalist asking the musician the
question i think every step of the way
from the block dance to the club to the
first record to that slippery wet moment
he thought that that was the highlight
and then
you couldn't believe that it kept
getting better
and from the fun
standpoint
it just always got better until you
didn't you know until you found other
things to to to keep you happy you know
to have fun with so right you know
this was this was good work good work if
you can get it and and we enjoyed every
minute of it
while still showing up for work
that's the thing yeah right right right
that's um
that's probably a very fine line
i was listening
yeah john have you heard the podcast
there's it's called um
uh the winds of change about the
scorpions yes
um were you on that plane were you on
that uh tour i was the one closed in the
shows pal yeah
oh my god
what i mean forget the plane forget the
flight but what what was it like being
over there did you
do did you guys understand
i mean was there any way to understand
the historical
significance of what you were doing
you have to remember the the other
intricacies of the whole thing that was
those
portraits that you see here on that wall
that's the that's my first manager so
that's oh
that's dr mcgee he was my doc he was my
first manager
and why we were going was he was in
trouble
um for having been involved in in
selling drugs
and how would we know you know how yes
he was going
legit by this time right and all that
stuff so
doc managed motley crew and bon jovi and
so he offered this concert
at a time when mad mothers against drunk
driving and all that was you know tipper
gore was in front of
congress talking about drugs and just
they know what nancy reagan and all that
kind of stuff so doc offers this let's
go to the soviet union and he's got
you know bon jovi at the height of
slippery's into new jersey we're pretty
big and then he's got motley crew and
ozzy osbourne and scorpions and we take
a new band called skid row and
cinderella and so you know we we now
have this festival that goes over to
play the soviet union but i was the
poster boy we went the winter before to
set it up and sell it and do the press
and all that stuff and then when we went
back in the summer of 89 to do the show
um
truthfully
i ended up staying in
well everyone else was out and doing
their thing and ultimately it's just
like
any old adage was and the singer went
home you know so i i wasn't out enjoying
it the way everyone else was
what did you think what's the point of
it like why are we doing this was it was
it oh we knew what it was no doc didn't
go to jail
you know i mean oh oh
[Laughter]
yeah wow yeah so yeah so the manager
didn't go to jail take one for the team
yeah so we we were gone wow and it was
you know it was meant to be something
legendary and all that kind of stuff
which
again folklore makes it bigger than it
was um yeah it was it was and it wasn't
and
it was crazy well
well john sorry to interrupt you um did
tom was that to tommy lee i mean yes
maybe you can't talk about this did he
really get that pissed you did this
yes yes so the the folklore
the folklore is this
we're all playing this show
we are commercially
the most successful of all the bands but
everybody's you know big in their own
right obviously and
um
ozzie and the scorpions have been around
a decade longer than the rest of us and
uh but we were insistent on closing the
show so everyone had egos in this whole
mess
and the first night we
and honestly we got our asses
kicked
by a german band called the scorpions
just absolutely annihilated the whole
magic of my band was my communicating
with the audience
and then telling these stories
and then singing these songs that you
hear on the radio
the scorpions were like a panzer tank
they didn't care about language
russia the soviet union
didn't know
rock and roll records if you had
a bon jovi record
you went to jail
what was that such thing wow
so yeah there was no oh yeah well here
comes one at dead or alive i'm gonna you
know
that didn't matter
so the second night
being you know like i said learning my
craft knowing what i do for a living i
went got it
second night i take a russian soldier i
trade him t-shirts and blue jeans like
you hear in all those great stories i
get his russian
soldier's uniform i say to the band
start playing the first song i'm going
to enter from the back of the stadium
don't go anywhere just stay on the intro
until i get there and i come through the
entire audience doing a strip tease the
gloves the hat the scarf the coat jump
up on the stage we win happenstance
a bunch of pyrotechnics goes off right
as i hit the stage did i have anything
to do with it
i don't know
but
needless to say no one kicked our ass
the second night
tommy turns to doc
punches them square in the face the
audience is going crazy we win the
second night
they they fire doc
and you know and
and that's true every word of it
happened well
because apparently there had been a
mandate that there should be there was
to be no pyrotechnics there was agreed
upon but desperate times desperate
measures rights right
oh john thank you for telling me that
hello hello again
[Music]
i really want to touch on the jon bon
jovi soul foundation um
doing such amazing work tackling the
problem of homelessness food insecurity
they launched a food bank in long island
where can people donate to that the jbj
seoul
foundation.org
uh i've had it for some 15 years now um
we build houses from coast to coast and
there's three jbj soul kitchens
that are our restaurants that there's no
prices on the menu if you want to affect
change directly if you were to come and
put 20 down on the table it paid for
your meal and and the meal for somebody
else in the restaurant who technically
are in need you'll never know who's in
need because it's communal seating and
those who are in need
especially but i i'd tell you that
you're missing out on a part of the
party if you didn't do it but they
volunteer
so we empower
any and everyone who comes
by volunteering which is what keeps our
overhead down so we have three of those
restaurants we had a food bank out on
long island for
during covet that was feeding 25 000
people out on eastern long island
god so we we've been doing that for a
number of years and i've had that
foundation for 15 years already and like
i said it's nearly a thousand houses
that we've built and the three
restaurants and uh
and a food bank when it was necessary so
it all works
um amazing uh there's no delicate segue
i i want to ask you about that your
rendition of here comes the sun
at the inauguration it's beautiful uh
really
really beautiful
do you feel extra pressure john
covering a song like that something from
an iconic artist um as i'm sure people
feel pressure covering your songs well
thank you for that too but um
when the inaugural committee were
putting the it together
um
then they they determined that they
wanted to
have people around the country
and were fearful of someone like me who
was in florida at the time traveling up
and bringing people from new york blah
blah blah so they said how about if you
do yours in miami and i said yeah and i
said i've got a great idea for you
instead of doing do what you can the
single from the record i would like to
do here comes the sun i think it's the
appropriate theme for trying to bring
people back together i'd like to do it
at dawn i'd like to do it you know on a
pier just outside of of lauderdale in
florida and so everybody said yeah yeah
great idea and so uh i was able to to
that's really cool um i like the way you
say dwan you have a slight still a
slight new jersey is that new jersey
yeah i
better better
uh this the song and video for story for
love it's it's so good uh
you incorporate home video footage why
was that song important for you to write
when um i'm wondering what have your
wife and kids taught you how they've
shaped your writing your music
well they're always an influence to some
degree right because they're a big part
of your life but because i realized like
i said this was such a topical record
one of the topics that we all really had
to come to terms with the last year was
family and so that song made it to the
final cut because we all got either
closer or certainly close to our
families for
these last 12 months so i think we all
had a different understanding
of our families today than we did even a
year ago so this funk made sense
to make the final cut of the record and
then
because i've written it about my family
i did hope that people would relate to
it as much and make it about their own
yeah well it's really uh it's beautiful
um
you uh do you ever think about changing
the band name to something other than
bon jovi and and
and why did you change the spelling it
was um your name is bonn with a g
uh was it just like people were like oh
is that guy over
was it just harder to say yeah yeah
people never pronounced it correctly
yeah yeah
and uh remember like i said the story
with runaway is i was on the radio and
had a record deal before there was a
band
right you know
the band wasn't um
you know on that early stuff and when
um
i was out promoting runaway with the
hope that i could get just a little more
cache in the community i one by one
asked what became these guys hey would
you play with me for a couple of weeks
because like i said you couldn't keep an
original band together there's no money
wow
and so yeah
so they they all said yes and one thing
led to another and then the first record
and uh
and they've been you know tico dave been
with me ever since
wow do you guys think you're just gonna
keep
touring i mean
you must miss it we talked a little bit
about that but uh do you think you'll be
like the stones and just keep doing it
i don't think so to be honest um you
know i have jokingly said forever i wish
the stones would retire only because i
could see where the end zone is
he just keeps going and mccartney keeps
going and bruce i'm going and i'm like
somebody lay down already you know
pressure
oh my god i i don't know i mean
paul mccartney is like 78 now and
can't wait to get back on the road
so i know bruce can't wait to get back
on the road me
i'm
12 13 15 years younger 18 years younger
than mccartney i don't see me doing this
in 18 19 years you know well and this is
not to say that they don't have that but
you must say that they're god bless them
they're great at they're doing it at the
top shelf you know level still i i
personally don't think i need to live
out of a suitcase
yeah you know at that age and phase of
my life but i love writing songs you
know i like writing songs when you write
a song you think it's good you want to
record it we
want to share it so one thing leads to
another but
i don't live to to get in you know
another hotel
mm-hmm yeah and that's a serious thing
right i don't know if people realize
that
that amount of touring i mean that's
that's becomes
what a year how long do you do for your
life and and it's
just physically and mentally taxing
you know it's just it is what it is it's
an incredible job it's been a
great adventure i'm going to do it next
year but i'm never going to do the 240
stroke tours again you know what we
would do on average
in those years when we were really
running hard we do 240.
i have no desire to do that right
john when when a song of yours which i'm
sure happens all the time when it comes
on the radio or um you're just out
randomly you're at a bar is it do you
get them what's that feel do you compare
i dated a girl who was in a band and i
would put her music on the thing and
her
scottish her bandmates would always get
embarrassed they would always get mad
why are you dude
[ __ ]
that's a [ __ ] beamer uh do you get do
you get like come on you guys
no no no again i'm past that you know
it's like i get it i know that a bunch
of these songs touch people's lives the
way music touched my life
and i've been in situations that
you know it just blows my mind that the
songs that we wrote
you know in my basement or richie's
basement or you know that kind of thing
have been on the radio for nearly 40
years and right it blows my mind that's
people singing them at uh ball games
yeah it's it's it's mind numbing it it's
just but it makes you want to do it
again it makes you want it again it
makes you want to be great again
i bet
that's why we keep doing it if we if i
were not doing it at the level that i'm
accustomed to i would be done i'd retire
but you know we keep having these big
hit records and playing the big stadium
so
it's all good
and what is uh this is a lightning round
really quick and i i i our time is very
limited uh unfortunately i could talk to
you for hours um
uh what is your most this is always the
embarrassing one to ask but uh i gotta
do it because it's a uniform thing uh
what is your most commonly used emoji
my teenage children i have them come in
and hit one of the emojis
all right
okay
which one
which ones today have they gotten you
into
i think there's i'm lucky if i get past
the smiley face or a birthday cake
that's okay that's as far as it goes
okay uh if you could be a professional
athlete um what sport would you play and
why oh i'd want to be tom brady
who wouldn't yeah
yeah he's such an inspiration
uh
i mean not always a great athlete but
he's a smart athlete he's a great guy
he's just a great guy who wouldn't want
to be tom brady
it's funny uh john we always i think on
every episode we've mentioned tom brady
and my brother was saying the other days
i do the show with my brother the intro
and the outro and he was saying you know
if people didn't know any better they
just tuned in for a couple snippets here
and there they might think it was a tom
brady themed podcast
i'm i'm good with that
um and i know you're close with
belichick and unfortunately we're uh
jets fans so uh god i feel for you even
yeah
yeah you should i really do
we thought darnold was our savior and um
yeah we got to figure it out um
oh you don't even have trevor lawrence
you even blew that one i know couldn't
even lose properly right right i'm
saying yeah about that
maybe deshawn watson um
if you if you could have one snack food
for the rest of your life your go-to
snack food your your
i don't know if you smoke stoned you
just get munchies maybe uh
m m's with peanuts he's the first oh my
it's my brother's yeah good one um he'll
like that answer uh what is your
favorite movie sequel we talking about
young guys
godfather too yeah
um
god that young guns too is fun though
isn't it i
yeah i love those movies yeah
i are you still close with those guys
and i was actually emilio not too long
ago as a matter of fact yeah and uh here
on occasion i'll run into kiefer or
christian slater uh but it was it was a
magical time in my life to be close with
those guys it's been great yeah i bet um
uh what is your it's funny to ask you
this what is your go-to karaoke song
i didn't i you know obviously i had
never been in a karaoke until um
i went into one uh uh with one of the
charities that had me disguise myself
and going so i'd never been in one
before
how did you just go what disguise did
you wear oh i don't know i just looked
like you know some kind of
derelict with long hair and a beard and
a mustache
but you know i went into a karaoke bar
i've never been in one ever
no [ __ ]
no no it's not like i go into karaoke
bars to sing i i i sing all the time
every day i didn't need to know i know
but
what did you sing john when you went
i don't think i did i i oh
what other people were singing
oh that's funny i i don't know if i
could do it now that i i think back
um who was your very first celebrity
crush
[Music]
sean's got a wistful look yeah cause i'm
trying not a very handsome wistful
looking far away look pfeiffer did
something special
enough and share uh in the 70s did
something very special too uh those are
the two first two that come to mind oh
yeah that's michelle pfeiffer heart to
beat up
yeah um
if you have to get a tattoo another
tattoo
what would you get
and where
oh my goodness
i don't think i could come up with one
tom brady yeah no
number 12
[Laughter]
just huge huge numbers on your chest
um what is your favorite fruit john
uh pineapple
uh-huh
uh
who who would you want to play you in
your biopic in the jon bon jovi story
uh
holly berry
oh nice i want holly barry to play
beyonce
just you know i can see that
here
i want to go to her meter and that's the
only way i'm going to get it
that's true that's a good point and
she'd have to study you you know she'd
have yeah
um
[Music]
[Laughter]
what is your who's your favorite um
muppet we mentioned the muppets earlier
did you watch the muppets uh you were
probably already a rock star by the time
they were
yeah right um yeah it would be the
sesame street characters uh
uh cookie monster i'm a
cookie monster
yeah your kids watched it sure sure
of course
are your kids impressed by
what you do i mean or did they get the
point you know my older kids are old now
they're
my my daughter's steph is 27 and jesse's
26.
they get it
and then the younger ones are are
18 and 17 and
they have come of age now they they get
it too now it's not just
some
abstract and in this last year has been
interesting because my youngest
has taken to music he's the only one of
the four and he's starting to write he
plays and sings and it covert that was
good for that you know so
i they're all very aware
but none of us live that kind of
you know thing
it's just not right my house
for a while i imagine it was just like a
thing that the reason dad wasn't here it
was like it was always more alive in the
neighborhood than in our house it was
like your dad is you know it's so like
my kids they didn't understand that but
they bring that home to us and you go oh
yeah i gotta explain to
mr smith we don't do that
but you know it gets to a time in a
place where i get it i embrace it i love
it i'm appreciative and we move on yeah
um
uh this is controversial dogs are cats
dog
hate cats not a cat yeah
this actually is controversial and i
don't you might not be able to answer it
but the beatles are the rolling stones
that's tough i like them both for
different reasons it was that the
beatles um
the songs were they were from another
planet that whole amazing singing and
cuteness was cool
and of course the stones have been my my
favorite rock band you know period like
he wanted to go up and beat mick jagger
you know i don't know mick jagger and i
really wish i did
you've never i've read it i've met him
i've struck his hand i don't know him
you're like i know paul mccartney yeah
well we mentioned here comes the sun
what would be another if you were to go
to a bar and put the beatles on the uh
chewbacca and the life is the song that
i sit there and go god where did it
come from
you know
paul
a thousand questions over the years
you know where did that come from and
how and
do you have a notebook of half thoughts
and
yeah that kind of stuff i've i've had
many a conversation
i'm blessed blessed blessed to actually
be able to call in my friend so you know
they were from another planet and i've
told them that i said george and john
just went home
yeah easy
great yeah well no he must be fair i can
only imagine ask does he that's a good
question does he have a bunch of he said
that every song
was written in a day
except for baby you could drive my car
and they had just run out of ideas and
he came back the next day and one of
them said
yeah move on and that was the end oh my
god that's the story
yeah oh my god in a day jesus christ
that's so cool you get to nerd
you get to kind of
that's cool you get to ask him that uh
questions like that oh
wow um well this has been cool for me to
get to ask you questions like this so
uh thank you so much for i know we're
over the time um but i could do this for
hours that you've been so easy and fun
thank you it's been a real pleasure
thank you
where am i talking to you today by the
way
uh well this is i can't i believe you
couldn't tell uh fairfield connecticut
oh you're interested in connecticut
you're not in l.a i'm
no no uh i live about five minutes from
where i grew up uh which has been good
during this yeah um
oh [ __ ] john i forgot to ask you uh
seinfeld or friends do you watch
i would have been a seinfeld guy
yeah okay
um and and so when when might you tour
again i mean is there a tentative plan
to get conversations have begun to start
in australia next february but
you know i think by then everything will
be open and
ready to go
i hope
yeah yeah yeah i i'm confident that
it'll start this fall but we'll go out
next year for for a bit yeah
okay well i look forward to it and i
can't wait for uh to hear the album 2020
and we'll talk all about the foundation
and uh thank you for all your work all
the music and for your time i really
appreciate it bye bye thank you sir
so so that happens yeah cool cool yeah
gravelly we're saying cool way too much
i'm getting self-conscious about it
it's uncool it's uncool to use that word
so much about one person you know we've
had cool guests on the show oh yeah like
matthew mcconaughey well i thought jane
goodall toby smulders yeah very cool um
who else is so many kevin bacon oh come
on i mean by the way people who are cool
our whole life yeah that's that's a very
for sure i hope he's listening they um
remind me of each other they too are
they bet they're friends i bet they know
each other why didn't i they have such
similar vibes they do they're similar
moods
that's not cool yeah they are i want
it it'd be weird if they weren't friends
you know would be a that'd be the
coolest matchmaking thing to do to set
those two up as friends
people wouldn't believe if i was the one
that set them up they'd be like i know
how'd you guys become friends you know
that nerd justin lost he set us up
oh
you know the more i think about it i
would be shocked if they oh maybe not
maybe weren't friends but
we're acquainted yeah definitely
definitely you know what was shocking is
that
shocking but it was a surprise that bon
jovi wasn't friendly with didn't really
know mick jagger
that is that was surprising and i
thought it was
cool that he admitted to like wanting to
be friends with like because he's like
into bon jovi he is mick jagger was
to what bon jovi is to a lot of kids
people our age of course
but but he is friends with so many paul
mccartney you know and it's hearing
in icon it's the first this is the first
time we've ever had a massive rock star
on the show
so it's there's something very strange
and cool about hearing him
talk about other iconic cool people like
bruce springsteen and paul mccartney in
such a casual way but
he can because he's on that level i know
but it's weird it's weird
i think of those people as being like he
describes the
beatles than another planet like they're
not real people
well that is that's what was so what
they are that it was almost disarming
about him is that uh he just was so easy
to talk to he just seems like a guy who
got out of like a regular guy yeah like
he avoided all of those that's why
how cool that he can like sort of like
reflect on
the his his career and like the things
he got to do and the fun he had he gets
he gets to be kind of wistful and like
somewhat romantic about it and and have
it in its place but also have this real
life like he seems like even when he
said about touring he's like i can't
imagine living out of a suitcase
anymore and like he's got this like
family seems like he likes his kids and
his wife you know he's just seems like
he avoided a lot of those pitfalls well
because i think we all have this
preconceived notion of rock stars
as being a certain way romanticism not
only that but but we
we imagine them having certain
flaws like you know certain ego issues
or or like diva issues where they need
to be they're spoiled i mean but he
uh hearing him talk and like i already
knew he was he did all this great
philanthropic work but
hearing him talk reminded me that
we so often judge people prematurely in
this in a similar way that i judged
uh louis anderson you know i judge
comedians as being kind of dark yeah
cynical and it just takes someone to
break that stereotype and come on and be
like oh he's just a regular guy yeah you
asked him what sport he would want to
play and he said
he said i don't want to be tom brady
yeah and you said ugh who wouldn't
i was so
excited to identify that someone else
brought up tom brady yeah somebody like
that yeah that's also like it's funny
that he would want to be him because i
always think
the people would want to be tom brady
are like uh you know the guys calling
into sports radio shows who are like 50
pounds overweight and like sort of
unhappy in their lives and but he is um
i would say in many ways seemingly on
par
with tom brady like it's funny that
he aspires to be something
i think he probably meant it more like
um
he's just like his friend and like he
people he's a good football player for
someone like bon jovi
there's like a small handful of people
that it would make sense that he would
want to aspire to be
right you know what i mean like like
nelson mandela no i'm saying in his in
his
world yeah mick jagger is one paul
mccartney's one yeah but there aren't
many there aren't many uh
musicians i know even who are like
uh higher than i
know of music but then you think like
forget
to
identify him just as a musician but as a
person you think like
to want to be somebody else or to aspire
to be like somebody else and this is a
controversial thing i don't know how to
bring up with him but i i keep thinking
about whenever i think of like mick
jagger paul mccartney these guys
i think of um
i mean they're still doing it they still
they must love doing it they play like
they love doing it and like he said
they're still at like top of their game
i know you're gonna say you you throw
paul simon into that category too yeah
their their hair
dying their hair they've another cool
thing about bon jovi they've done
certain things to make them look younger
there's a degree of vanity sure that is
on display that bon jovi doesn't seem to
have i agree it makes him cooler i don't
think there's anything wrong with
someone dying their hair right
especially especially if it's madison
reed or a sponsor of course not
nor do i have a problem with people
doing things to their face to make them
look if that makes you feel good then
you know go for all power to you right
but i also
think it's
cool
to not do that mm-hmm so when you're in
a position where like a rock star is
there must be so much pressure on people
on them to
stay young looking and relevant and yeah
and maybe that's a big thing with actors
and maybe bon jovi's you could argue oh
he's just lucky he like
his face is still really handsome
and his hair is cool so it's white so
it's like a light gray it's it looks
cool so it's a different color i think
that about it's weird i have this and
this is from the time i grew up and the
cultural norms that have been like
established in my
world and you know my experience is that
for women to maybe because our mother
did it for a while and that would but
for women to dye their head isn't weird
to me but it's
for men to do men and especially like
you said
somebody who's like a rock star and like
con you should be like confident in how
you like you you like need jet and also
i know but again in their late 70s you
can have jet black hair but again weird
but again the fl
the flip side of that argument is that
because they're rockstars because
they're actors
um because they're in like a
quote-unquote young person's profession
they have to keep they have extra
pressure on them to
keep their youth and to be marketable i
know i do think that they're
i do
sympathize with that well in pom simon's
case hopefully future guest i'm sure
he's not listening but like that
stuff he did is i think is
just makes him look so different and now
well that that wasn't his intention his
intention probably was
to stay younger looking i know we
shouldn't judge no but we are we are
well but he still is cool i mean like
that's the thing i
my it's surprising to me because the
music paul mccartney how does it get you
can't get cooler than paul simon
mccartney mick jagger and yet there's a
degree of it's like
like you say you don't know anyone until
you like sit down with them and like
i don't know he must have insecurities
about that you're right they must that
there's no other explanation to like
them doing stuff like that to themselves
other than like they have insecurities
like everyone else does right everyone
has insecurities yeah yeah except bon
jovi
i don't think i'm ever gonna dye my hair
but
that's not because i'm above it it it
just means it's because i don't
i'm not at any sort of level where
people are looking at me and like
judging me
like they are with some other people
mistakes for me are so low yeah that
it's easy for me to say oh i'm not gonna
dye my hair i don't care if my hair goes
gray i think i would like but if i was a
big rock star
i might have a different answer well
here's my hypocrisy my hypocrisy is it
is
important enough to me to have like to
not have gray hair only because um
because i i
i it make it like the idea of aging is
like something i struggle with and like
getting older and time passing by that's
so for me to have gray hair be like it'd
be a reminder that like oh i'm i'm
getting up there and i'm and i also am
like sort of happy that i have so few i
have a couple you do have a couple i
have a couple too me too
but like i'm i'm happy that it's still a
couple gray hairs couple gray hairs yeah
but it's also like if when my face which
it's starting to gets like
starting to look older um i wouldn't
want so i wouldn't dye my hair only
because i think it looked weird it
looked like it it would be i think if a
look fake it would be a weird contrast a
contrast between an older looking face
and like jet lag but right now you're
lucky you still have a pretty boyish
face so if you add gray hair now it
would be
um it wouldn't quite match you know
because you have a face that suggests
you're still pretty young and you're not
ready for gray hair well i remember
thinking that about our uncle remember
when uncle john started going gray i
remember thinking like oh we that's
straight strange i didn't like i kind of
forgot he was
that that
age where you would get gray hair right
he always had such a boyish yeah and to
me he was always like that age and yeah
i guess maybe i don't know well we've
we've really exhausted i digress
uh he's you asked him what his favorite
karaoke song to do oh man and he was
like i've never
been to a karaoke yes it's like he's so
unfamiliar with it because he's never
had to do it because he's always been a
rock star i know every knows the
teenager if he's never had the itch to
do karaoke he scratches it by going on
stage at madison square garden and
singing his own songs i know it's like i
i faced this a couple weeks ago with
dr jane goodall when i was like i
couldn't even ask her because i
you know i just avoided the i couldn't
ask her because like she's definitely
never done
karaoke and if she has like well i lose
out i didn't but i knew she hadn't um
but it was almost as weird now i wish
you had asked her i know just to hear
how she had said living on a prayer
i believe it's living on a prayer it's
the only one i ever do
yeah it was funny but then i i do wish
i'd asked bon jovi um john
uh
what if he's ever like overheard people
he must have if it's weird to overhear
people singing his
his songs because like especially living
on a prayer is like oh my god
there's a handful of bon jovi songs that
are
constantly played and displayed and like
sung karaoke yeah when i say sporting
events
ball games ball games
living on a prayer is a song that is i
always hear people do karaoke oh yeah
and i almost never hear it done well
it's always attempted karaoke i've heard
it so many times it's like one of the
most popular karaoke songs but it people
never do it well because it's such a
hard song to say yeah yeah that's a real
and people do when they do that
but they do when they get like i can
only see
like sloppy people doing who have like
extra confidence that's the song you do
like you're like pretty drunk you need
to have the yeah you need to have like a
lot of liquid courage
uh and it's yeah you never hear it
you're right i never hear i've heard
that song so many times at karaoke it's
never good
bon jovi's the only one who can sing
that song that's true
that's true um so you wish now i was
also imagining him going to the karaoke
when he had the
he said his his um
disguise was like a beard oh he must
have been horrified hearing some of the
songs god yeah it must be hard just
butchering his songs uh let's read a
letter
okay
this is a letter from chloe rose
schwartz
subject
thanks for being real human beings oh
it's a funny thing to be thanked for
isn't it
to be real to be a real human being
well i i have to i don't think she meant
it literally right now i know
uh thanks chloe sorry to immediately
shame your very nice compliment
thank you hey justin and christian my
name is chloe i'm 28 and i live in a
small town in florida ah lucky
with my husband and our dog cheddar i've
been a long time listener of the podcast
and i'm a big fan and try to share it
with as many people as i can well thank
you chloe we appreciate it
justin back to chloe justin funny enough
so many of your movies are the backdrop
to my adolescence without me even really
realizing it galaxy quest crossroads and
she says hashtag free brittany i gotta
see that and my g d
a g slash d and my g you've never seen
that god it's when you can't write
it's it's like sacrilegious to write
g.o.d
i've never seen that you've never seen
that no maybe i know a lot of religious
people
i just correspond with the secretary
i've started to shame you but i am very
surprised i guess i you know i've seen
it in in the context of i've seen it
when it's god
gd damn
oh you have yeah i think i've seen that
but i don't think i've ever seen it on
its own and my and my god i can't count
how many times i rented accepted from
blockbuster when i'd stay home from
school sick
you should've just bought it i missed
blockbuster i do too i know there's one
you both have to miss blockbuster
there's a oh you know what there's a
documentary that i should mention really
quickly if you do if you're like us and
miss blockbuster uh there's a
documentary about it about the last
blockbuster that my friend was just
promoting
and now i can't find it anyway google it
it's
the last blockbuster i think there's one
left in in the pacific northwest anyway
um but then why did you rent it so many
times just buy it i've seen it so many
times in
like cheap bins stop shaming chloe
i'm shaming my own movie it's in the
cheap ends oh right and chloe for her um
but it's nice it rented it that many
times back to chloe anyways i just
wanted to send a note over to both of
you to tell you that you are really
putting so much goodness into this world
at a time we need it most i know that
anytime i listen to an interview on your
show it's going to be filled with
humanity and genuine curiosity you are
both always seem to be so honored to
speak to whoever may be on that day and
seem to actually enjoy talking to them
so many people have podcasts these days
but many of them sound like just another
thing they are doing because everyone
else is yours stands out because you so
clearly care and you so clearly enjoy it
i also love to listen to your sibling
banter it reminds me so much of me and
my brother
cool the point of me saying all this is
that you both have inspired me to try to
give more of that genuine curiosity
humanity and acceptance of others in my
daily life wow i think we can all agree
this year with [ __ ] and we saw so many
things that made me question where our
humanity has gone you guys have
continued to defy that it's really a
beautiful thing to enjoy listening to
and learning from someone else and
you've helped me rediscover how to do
that now i try to be more like that each
day thank you for your genuine
conversation and for being such a light
i can't wait to keep listening
wow
sending sunshine chloe what uh what a
nice letter
i mean
was nothing nicer thank you chloe i i um
yeah i mean wouldn't i
i it would be nice to have some of that
sunshine now i'm looking out at a
gray dreary freezing cold
day i miss florida i do too and small
town florida really cool but uh we're
right around the corner from
first of all the vaccine chris and i get
the vaccine pretty soon
and also spring
yeah we're eligible very soon yeah just
heard um
well uh hopefully you are all staying
safe you chloe
guys think it's really kind letter and
if you guys would like to write in any
letter doesn't have to be as kind as
that um our email address is life is
short at wundery.com
and thank you to our
rockstar guest
i have a question for you an iconic rock
star guest john bon jovi yeah i um i
have a i have a would you rather for you
okay uh would you rather um
have to have a uh
an unlit cigarette just dangling out of
your mouth all the time
or um wherever you or all the time be
carrying a boombox that's playing living
on a prayer
the cigarette
easy but you can play it softly gently
you can play it like it doesn't have to
be blasting just if it was an unlit
cigarette versus carrying a boombox that
was making no noise sounds
i would still pick the cigarette you
would carry a boombox everywhere a
cigarette an unlit cigarette in my mouth
you'd look like such a turd i don't i'd
get over it
every time you look like carrying a boom
box i know but they have smaller boo
you're thinking of like a big 80s style
like boombox run dmc like that's a
boombox
boomboxes aren't three inches tall some
boomboxes what you're thinking the word
boom like it's supposed to be like a big
yeah you can you can have like a box
like of like a six inch am i putting it
on my shoulder yeah you have to carry it
on your shirt then no it's more work
it's as simple as that oh you've sean is
bigger
and harder to carry
yeah but you look ah okay if the
question was a boombox making sound or a
lit cigarette all the time
i'd have to think about it think about
it you'd want a lipstick i wouldn't want
it but i wouldn't inhale i'd learn no
but you'd be anywhere you go you but you
couldn't go inside you you'd have to you
get kicked out of everywhere because
you'd be
you don't think you get kicked out if
you were playing carrying around a
boombox that was playing music remember
we were on the beach in north carolina
and those kids were running around with
a that boombox i think maybe that's what
made me think of it and they were like
they seemed like they thought they were
cool they were like blasting this music
this like shitty music i felt so old
yeah i wouldn't want to do that
yeah i also wouldn't want a little
cigarette i haven't smoked a cigarette
since i was uh 28 it was a i was
uh one week shy of my 29th birthday wow
so i haven't smoked a cigarette in over
10 years
i wonder if bon jovi ever he must have
smoked cigarettes he sounds like he does
yeah but i'm sure he doesn't anymore
once you've learned how like dumb and
dangerous it was i would guess he
doesn't smoke yeah but he's also to hit
those high notes on living on a prayer
how do you do that if you're a smoker i
know i like yeah anyway well anyway
thanks we'll ask him next time yeah
uh guy did you notice how i was fishing
for an invitation to one of his shows i
was like oh man i can't wait to yeah
you're like i can't wait to be in the
front row in australia yeah
uh yeah
such so much thanks to him and um if you
would like to check out his great work
and if you would like to maybe donate to
this food bank that he started you can
go to jbj
soulkitchen.org another good thing to be
doing is listening to music just putting
headphones on and listening to an entire
album so i encourage you to do that with
2020 his new album um speaking uh giving
voice to these crazy times we're living
in and uh thank you to all of you who
are listening to our crazy voices and
we'll talk to you next week
[Music]
life is short is hosted by me just me
justin long
it's co-hosted and produced by you
christian long also produced by one
megan monaco the senior producer on this
and all of the past maybe 99 episodes is
michelle me bland and when it comes to
audio engineering who else gets their
hands on this one but none other than
joe enriquez and the executive producer
is mark marshall for wondering
i'm saying
how i view
sexy and sexy cool yeah
where like do you think anthony keatis
is cool
yeah he's sexy right and cool
there's no such thing as sexy but not
cool i know but there's not sexy for men
as far as oh really yeah i think michael
jordan i can name
you're saying jordan's not sexy
no he's sexy he's very sexy what about
john stockton
he's not really sexy but he's i think
he's sexy
i'm not saying he's like the most
handsome guy in the world yeah i guess
he's sexy yeah he's gonna be kind of
like yeah yeah yeah i guess he is i
guess he's sexy people go together yeah
they do
sting is uh
that's funny my instinct is to say that
he's cool see i would say about a man
there's no such thing as the cool man
who's not sexy
and there's also no such thing as a sexy
guy who's not cool i'm like michael
caine michael caine's cool i'm sexy yeah
yeah yes i guess try to name a guy who's
cool but not sexy and vice versa oh i
don't think he'll do it
you